welcome to this video I'm playing ponga
Pongo Pongo Pongo from the Netherlands
don't die never played him before he's
got no name new account probably okay
the Scandinavian so one of those
openings I don't really like to face in
those blitz games because well I'm not a
regular a four player and while I have
some ideas about many openings this is
mostly because i have studied studied
quite a number of lines for black and
very often i have some idea because i
had looked at it there's black years ago
but this is not the case for the
scandinavian this is really one of the
openings i really never studied not
because it's so terribly bad it's just
like there never was any need to i
always had other things to to study oh
bring wise yeah be 630 pledge really
quickly end this and it's a strange move
I think weakening the light squares or
not considering that this Bishop is out
on age five Group D one jumps designed
to prepare 95 sure not nice
gaining a temple basically for h3y 195
or not what about d5 actually yeah this
is in fact interesting because of the
good development he lost quite quite
some time
not sure what you should should do now
it already looks some very dangerous
threatening to take on e6 and there's
also d6 it's very hard not to take 25 at
the moment but what's the next move CDC
DM yeah this is very ugly but hard too
hard to suggest something good for black
and interesting yeah well I just take it
and make sure to get something on the
light squares Wow and then Bishop g6
really ah ah i played this hard too
quickly yeah I really let him back into
the game this is very very bad look at
the snow is activating and I don't have
a square for my queen only this rotten
gt2 square ah after this night g5 was
really terrible ok the only good thing
is it's still a good position probably
but I probably could could have could
have gotten more
someone get seen I'm in this F file not
too not too convenient
yeah the Queen position is a bit tricky
but I wasn't sure that should we treated
it also irritates him a bit
and I can detect the queen with Bishop
f8 for instance but then I just dropped
back to g3 it's not clear that it helps
mata ji for even a deform why not you
for not running into a direct attack
Jim Bishop f4 just a text the queen but
it's not really connected to a specific
plan show p.m. amy young tech c6h6 where
do i go then and I to you for h6 root
yet I can take care making the square
one h3 very tricky
not exactly great
yeah I am bad certainly had better
better better possibilities but he's
he's taking his time this is quite a
white noise Bishop g6 mmm-hmm Bishop f5
Bishop c5 ok let's drop back the Queen
on default is very irritating probably
for both of us now I can just doesn't
just win a piece I have that covered
yeah black resigned hmm yeah it did a
bit of a strange game really around here
why does watch should just win but
somehow this is a good move
okay he's writing me one define was a
mouse limit and really wanted to play
the Scandinavian does he have no has no
name so I some likelihood that I know
him from the Dutch league who didn't
didn't write anything who is this yeah
and here yeah this is not so easy I know
he's getting ton of activity here this
is just just very very strange stuff I
have a pawn but it's not easy to play
the comp at least with this very quick
playthrough world likes why'd he had
says bishop g6 is good yeah yeah of
course it is yeah this is nice read take
and black wins yeah this was very tricky
it was wasn't really a convincing
convincing performance with this was
surprisingly complicated to this type of
position with load time unfortunately he
took even more time and this was
basically the decider in this game
alright thanks for watching